In this lesson, we will talk just briefly
about buffer bloat. We saw an example of
buffer bloat in the last lesson where we
explored the latency effects of power boost. In the
example we explored, the sender could send at
a rate R that was bigger than the sustained
rate R without seeing packet loss. Now if
there's a buffer in the network that can support
this higher rate, what we'll see is that buffer
will start filling up with packets. But this buffer
can still only drain at the sustained rate R.
So even though the sender might be able to
send at a faster rate for a brief period
of time in terms of throughput, all of those
packets that the sender sent at that faster rate
are queued up in line waiting to be sent.
As these packets are waiting in this buffer,
they'll see higher delays than they would see
if they simply arrived at the front of
the queue and could be sent immediately. The delay
that the packet will see in the buffer is the amount of data in the buffer
divided by the rate that the buffer can
drain. These large buffers can introduce delays that ruin
the performance for time-critical applications such as
voice and video. These large buffers actually show
up all over the place. In home routers, in home WiFi devices or access points,
in hosts on device drivers, and also
in switches and routers. Let's take an example
of buffer bloat that we observed in home routers as part of the Bismarck study
that I described in the last lesson.